Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Jakob Olgun. Ich bin Assistenz als Auf-Dieser-Station tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmeglisch befürchten. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Natürlich gerne.
Okay, beginnen wir mit Ihrem Namen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Markus Schmitz.
Markus mit C oder mit K?
Mit C.
Mit M.
Danke schön.
Wie alt sind Sie?
37 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Ich bin 1988 geworden.
1980?
Genau dort war.
25. Januar.
Danke schön.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schmitz?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,80 m groß.
Wiege momentan 75 kg.
75 kg. Danke schön, Herr Schmitz.
Okay, was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Schmitz? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich bin seit längerer Zeit extrem müde.
Bin wenig belastbar.
Ich habe Muskelkrämpfe.
Ich muss sehr viel Wasser lassen.
Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt.
Ich bin Sportler.
Aber ich kriege mein normales Trainingspensum nicht mehr geregelt.
Sie haben seit vielen Jahren ...
Seit einiger Zeit, einigen Monaten.
Seit einem Monat?
Einigen Monat.
Okay, tut mir leid.
Seit einigen Monaten haben Sie Muskelschwäche abgestiegen.
Muskelkrämpfe.
Muskelkrämpfe, Schwäche.
Ich muss viel Wasser lassen.
Ich bin sehr schnell erschöpft.
3-4 Monate.
Wie viel Wasser lassen Sie pro Tag?
Ich muss sehr oft.
8 Mal.
Im Auftrag?
Nachts auch.
Was machen Sie?
Welche Sportarten treiben Sie?
Ich laufe viel.
Ich fülle die Sportarten und fahre Rennrad.
Jetzt haben Sie eine Schmerze?
Ich habe Muskelkrämpfe.
Jetzt?
Jetzt auch nicht.
Aber immer wieder.
Nennen Sie in der letzten Zeit eine neue Medikamente?
Ich nehme gar keine Medikamente.
Haben Sie Fiber oder füllen Sie sich fibrig?
Gar nicht.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Mussten Sie schon erbrechen?
Ich habe keine Übelkeit.
Ich habe recht.
Wie viel Wasser haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Ich habe 5 Kilo abgenommen.
In den letzten 2 Monaten.
Das ist geplante.
Wegen der Sport.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber es kommt mir sehr viel vor.
Normalerweise nehme ich nicht so schnell ab.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das tut mich gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Schwitzen Sie viel?
Wenn ich Sport mache, dann schwitze ich viel.
In der Nacht aber auch?
Nein.
Haben Sie keine Beobachtung?
Haben Sie Verdankensprobleme?
Nein.
Aber für 3 Monate, für 4 Monate
haben Sie etwas Neuigkeiten?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Neuigkeiten.
Wie meines Erachtens.
Ich habe vor 4 Monaten, alles war in Ordnung für Sie.
Alles war in Ordnung?
Ja.
Herr Schimmit, gibt es Ihnen vorgeschichte
wichtigen Erkrankungen?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keinen Medikament.
Nein.
Es ist nur ein Gelt.
Ich bin also täu-täu-täu-täu-tüch gesund normalerweise.
Okay, Glückwunsch, Gott sei Dank.
Wurde sie schon mal operiert, Herr Schmidt?
Ich war noch nie im Krankenhaus.
Okay.
Und da war...
Reagieren Sie allergisch auf etwas?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Und ich möchte noch ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familie stellen.
Und sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer...
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten,
und denen ich wissen, wie es ist, zum Beispiel bei einem Vater
oder bei der Mutter,
bei der Tochter, oder Herzprobleme?
Also beide haben Bluthochdruck, das ist mir bekannt.
Mutter auch?
Mütter auch?
Mütter, auch?
Vater auch?
Beide.
Beide haben Bluthochdruck, die nehmen auch Medikamente ein.
Meine Mutter hat eine Schilddrösenunterfunktion, glaube ich,
oder Überfunktion, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Mein Vater hat auch Blutzucker.
Die Blutzucker, ist Athezucker oder?
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Ihre Mutter hat Bluthochdruck und Schilddrösenprobleme.
Genau.
Außer dieser Krankheiten noch etwas gibt es?
Ist mir nicht bekannt, weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Oh, gut.
Jetzt möchte ich auch noch ein paar Fragen über Ihre Leveski-Wanheit.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Schmidt?
Nein, noch nie.
Oh, sehr gut, ich gratuliere Sie.
Denken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, vielleicht einmal oder zweimal im Jahr.
Am Jahr?
Ich versuche mich gesund zu ernähren.
Ich bin Sportler
und bin auch sehr zufrieden gewesen.
Aber das, was ich jetzt habe, das beruhigt mich sehr.
Und das ist auch eine Frage.
Ich weiß, ich vermute dieses Antwort, aber nehmen Sie Drogen?
Wie bitte?
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen nehme ich nicht einmal.
Drogen, ja, genau.
Und was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin Ingenieur.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Oder sind Sie ledig?
Ich bin ledig.
Leben Sie allein oder mitgeben in dem Zusammenhang?
Ich liebe alleine.
Okay.
Und möchten Sie noch etwas ergänzen?
Nein, ich würde gern wissen, was das ist.
Ich meine, woran liegt das, dass ich so schwach bin, so müde bin,
diese Muskelkremfe habe,
immer wieder Toilette, Trinken muss.
Eigentlich, ja.
In dieser Situation gibt es viele Krankheiten.
Es gibt viele Krankheiten, in die wir Schwerten verursachen können.
Im Moment kann ich nicht etwas genauer sagen.
Kann das Schlimmes sein?
Wie bitte?
Kann das etwas Schlimmes sein, was gefährlich ist?
Eigentlich denke ich nicht schlimmes sein.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall Untersuchungen durchführen
und ein paar Labo-Tests oder ein paar Apparative und Diakostik durchführen.
Welche?
Unsere.
Welche sind die?
Ich habe sie erledigt.
Sie haben sie erledigt?
Ja.
Das ist sicher.
Ich habe noch nie Probleme mit der Schilddrüse.
Wie bitte?
Ja, ich finde...
Ich finde, das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Ich wäre aber nicht zufrieden.
Ich bin immer wieder zufrieden.
Aber ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Ich habe noch nie Probleme mit der Schilddrüse.
Ich bin immer wieder zufrieden.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Aber können wir auch unbedingt überprüfen?
Ja, das wäre super.
Ja, und wie ist Ihre Unglichkeit?
Haben Sie Heißung? Sind Sie Heißung?
Ich habe keine Heißung, mein Appetit ist normal.
Appetit ist normal?
Ich trinke viel in der letzten Zeit.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Sehstörung bemerkt?
Ne, Sehstörung habe ich nicht gehabt.
Nein.
Nur diese Muskelkämpfe machen mir zu schaffen.
Okay, herrsch ich mit.
Ich habe aus meiner Sicht alle wichtigen Fragen gesteckt.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen oder etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich möchte gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Ja, ich auch.
Aber wie gesagt, vielleicht das verdacht auf eine Ska-Krankheit sein.
Ska-Krankheit?
Ja, könnte sein.
Okay.
Sind Sie im Moment jetzt nüchtern?
Ja, ich bin nüchtern.
Okay, gut.
Machen wir jetzt einfach eine Fukratest.
Ja.
Können wir auch vielleicht ein paar Informationen sammeln?
Okay.
So, herrsch ich mit.
Möchten Sie noch etwas fragen oder?
Nein.
Bitte schön, Sie können die im Wartezimmer warten, abwarten, dann komme ich wieder.
Alles klar.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Ja, ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Bitte.
Herr Schmidt, haben Sie bemerkt, im Letzter sei Trollkennahaut und Yukreis?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Vielleicht haben die Beine ein bisschen trocken geworden, das kann sein, aber sonst nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie in der Letzter Seite beim Urin eine Farbeveränderung bemerkt?
Nein.
Er ist klar.
Komplett klar, weil ich auch viel trinke.
Und fühlen Sie sich pfügig?
Nein.
Haben Sie etwas genommen, ohne Muskeln aufzubauen?
Nein, gar nichts.
Ich bin nicht so ein Typ.
Danke.
Haben Sie bemerkt, im Letzter sei häufiger Erkältung oder mehr dauernd Erkältung bemerkt?
Gar nicht.
Normalerweise bin ich wirklich nie krank.
Ich bin eigentlich sehr gesund, für mich sehr wohl.
Herr Schmidt, haben Sie auch Taupaisgefühl oder Krippel?
Oder was?
Krippel.
Ja, Krippel.
Ja, vielleicht in den Unterschenkel, in den Waden habe ich das ein bisschen, aber es sind ja so kramfartige Sachen.
Na, kramfartige.
Und haben Sie in der Letzter Seite einen Seken bis oder bemerkt oder Insekten bemerkt?
Seken bis, haben Sie gesagt.
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ich war auch nicht im Haus, ich war hier die ganze Zeit abgearbeitet.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Prostatum?
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Sagen Sie mir das.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Gibt es nicht Fragen?
Oder?
Gute Anfragen.
Ja.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberast.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen, deswegen möchte ich vorstellen, haben Sie sie für mich eine kurze Zeit?
Ja.
Es handelt sich um ein Markus Schmidt.
Er ist ein junger Patientin, 37 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,80 Meter groß und 75 Kilo.
Er stellte sich seit ca. 3-4 Monaten krampfen und erhöhte eine Irrenfrequenz.
Er stellte sich vor.
Außerdem klagte er über Patik und Astheni.
Er ist Sportler, er macht regelmäßig Sportler.
Er kann laufen jeden Tag, ich bin mir unter Rat.
Jeden Tag?
Ich glaube nicht jeden Tag, aber er macht regelmäßig Sport.
Regelmäßig.
Ja.
In der Legislatur an Amnesien fand er sich von 5 Kilo in 2 Monaten Gewichtverlust.
Die Frage nach Pilexie, Nausea, Amnesis und Beustinverlust und in Appetenz, alle Fragen verneint.
An Vorerkrankungen ist keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt.
Auch sie wurden nie operiert.
Er wurde nie operiert, er nehme keine Medikamente regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein.
Bei ihm sind keine Allergien bekannt.
In der Familienanamnesie gab es bei Vater arterielle Hypertonie und Diabetes Melitus.
Und auch bei Mutter arterielle Hypertonie und Hypertroide erkennt nicht die richtige Diagnose.
Er ist einselkend, keine Geschwister.
An Nausea gab es nicht Raucher und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er ist sehr selten, ein oder zwei Mal, Alkohol trinken pro Jahr.
Er ist Ingenieur, lebt und lebt allein.
Die anamnestischen Angaben und Beschwerden ernten am ersten auf Diabetes Melitus hin.
Wie kommen Sie darauf?
Er ist mindestens acht Mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Poliuri?
Genau.
Und er fühlt sich erschöpft.
Deswegen denke ich, dass auch familiäre Prädispositionen sind.
Ist er nicht zu jung für Diabetes?
Eigentlich können wir nicht so viel, nicht häufig.
Aber können wir zur Sicherung testen.
Wie kann man das testen?
Einfach ein Blutzucker testen.
Er ist nüchtern.
Nach dieser Vorstellung werde ich die Patienten untersuchen.
Er ist auch ein Blutzucker.
Er kommt in Betracht Hypertereuse.
Er ist ne Frotisches Zünderung.
Er hat auch Unterschenkeldämer.
Wie bitte?
Eigentlich habe ich nicht gefragt.
Nach der Untersuchung kann ich auch wieder nachfragen.
Eine frotische Symptome muss man immer an Unterschenkeldämer nachfragen.
Genau.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich körperliche Untersuchungen und Blut-Testen.
Z.B. Blutzucker und Schilddürsenwerte.
Auch Nierenwerte prüfen.
Dann habe ich eine Symptome.
Ja, habe ich eine sehr langzeitige Symptome.
Können wir auch das unbedingt machen?
Und Blutbild machen Sie sicherlich auch?
Ja, dann müssen wir auch Gucke, z.B. eine Anime oder etwas aussuchen.
Nach der Bestätigung meiner Verdachtdiagnose werde ich die Patienten empfehlen.
Um die Medikamente je nach der Untersuchungsergebnisse zu planen.
Eigentlich im Moment kann ich nicht mehr...
Das klingt ja sehr nach einem Diabetes-Meditus.
Richtig.
Aber er ist zu jung für ein Diabetes-Meditus.
Gibt es verschiedene Formen von Diabetes-Meditus?
Was glauben Sie?
Was denken Sie?
Ich gehe nicht für Typ 1, er ist alt.
Aber für Typ 2, er ist jung.
Deswegen er steht im mittleren Seite.
Wie bei Typ 1,5?
Ja.
Es gibt diese Formen, die ein Bischwilz sind.
Und Diabetes-Meditus nennt man die.
Wie heißen diese Formen?
1 plus 2.
Man nennt sie auch 1,5, aber weil er zwischen 1 und 2 ist.
Aber es gibt einen Namen dafür.
Lada.
Latent, Autie, Immuna, Diabetes-Meditus, bei Adults.
Also eigentlich Erwachsenenalter.
Das ist selten, aber kann vorkommen.
Wie kann man das denn...
Weil Sie haben Recht, er ist zu jung für ein Diabetes-Meditus Typ 2.
Er ist nicht Sportler, er ist nicht abhüpfös.
Also eine Insulinresistenz ist unwahrscheinlich.
Aber er ist zu alt für ein Diabetes-Meditus Typ 1.
Das ist meistens vor dem 30. Lebensjahr, dass man das feststellt.
Er ist schon knapp 40, er ist 37 Jahre alt.
Man kann das in Blut bestimmen oder nachweisen,
ob er einen sogenannten Latent-Aute-Immunen-Diabetes hat.
Wissen Sie, wie das geht?
Haben Sie das schon gehört?
Ja, nein.
Nein, ich habe es auch nicht gehört.
Man kann Antikörper bestimmen.
Diese GAD-Antikörper.
Aber was wichtiger ist, ist auch, dass Sie das C-Peptid bestimmen.
C-A-P?
C-Peptid.
Und wenn die auffällig sind,
dann kann man ausgehen, dass es ein Typ 1 Diabetes ist, nicht Typ 2.
Das wird später insulinpflichtig.
Noch können Sie die mit MedFormin vielleicht therapieren,
aber die werden zeitnah in den nächsten Monaten,
Jahre insulinpflichtig werden.
Das ist wichtig.
Es verläuft langsamer als ein Typ 1 Diabetes.
Okay?
Verstehe ich.
Danke schön, Herr Oberast.
Wird das C-Peptid normal sein oder erniedrig sein?
Was glauben Sie?
Ich glaube, wenn das ein Antikörper ist,
dann wird es erhöhter.
Erhöht?
Das ist eigentlich das Teil in den Ingeniegen.
Deswegen, ich warte niedrig sein.
Genau. Normal bis niedrig.
Es kommt auch noch, wie der HB1C ist.
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Hat der ein HB1C von 15 oder hat der ein HB1C von 6,7,
7,7,1, das in welcher Stufe ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist ja noch in der Anfangsphase.
Wir können C-Peptid als Insulin.
C-Peptid ist die Vorstufe von Insulin.
Mussten Sie nochmal nachlesen.
Biochemie.
Gut, bin ich gut.
gute Fragen gestellt. Ich denke, die Diagnose war auch einfach. Nur das Alter, man muss oft auch an
Menschen denken, die jung sind, können trotzdem ein Typ 1 Diabetes haben. Nicht immer müssen
diese sehr, sehr jung sein. Wenn wir ihr Diabetologen oder Endocrinologen haben, die können natürlich
gerne ihren Beitrag dazu leisten hier in der Runde. Wie wissen das bestimmt besser als ich? Gibt es Diabetologen oder?
Haben wir hier Diabetologen oder Endocrinologen, die es sich outen möchte?